من الورق الى الشاشه افلام اكتسبت نصها من
الروايات العربيه واصبحت الاشهر على
الساحه السينمائيه اللص والكلاب روايه
عربيه للكاتب العالمي نجيب محفوظ تحولت
الى فيلم انتج عام
1962 بطوله شكري سرحان شاديه سمير صبري
وكمال الشناوي في بيتنا رجل روايه الكاتب
المصري احسان عبد القدوس تحولت الى فيلم
انتج عام
1964 بطوله الفنان العالمي عمر الشريف
والفنان حسن يوسف رجال في الشمس رائعه
الكاتب الفلسطيني غسان كنفاني تحولت الى
فيلم سينمائي بعنوان المخدوعون وحصدت
الجائزه الذهبيه لمهرجان قرطاج الافلام
العربيه والافريقيه لعام
1973 روايه تراب الماس الكاتب المصري احمد
مراد والتي تحولت الى فيلم من انتج في عام
2018 ولعب بطولته الفنان المصري ياسين
والنجوم من عزت العلايلي ماجد الكدواني
بيومي فؤاد ومحمد ممدوح
[موسيقى]